bonjour vous êtes avec nous sur le
canton de kingersheim canton de huit
communes avec bien entendu la commune la
plus importante qui ait kingersheim face
tâte lutterbach du sud armor sonnèrent
le glas
on a aussi heinz brand galfingue et
reiningue qui sont des communes plus
rurales et nous nous sommes nous nous
trouvons ici devant l'abbaye de
l'oelenberg sur la commune de reiningue
qui est un lieu emblématique de notre
canton mais aussi à lieu tellurique
d'alsace et où vous trouverez aussi un
magnifique magasin monastique qui est
d'ailleurs le plus grand de france
alors pour nous présenter je crois que
nous avons la chance de travailler
très spontanément ensemble un binôme qui
est très à l'écouté des communes du de
notre canton comme nos autres collègues
mais nous prenons beaucoup de plaisir à
cette mission et que nous nous
répartissons de manière assez équilibré
pour répondre le mieux possible à la
proximité de notre territoire et en
termes de proximité je crois que nous
sommes particulièrement attachés aux
valeurs que représente le monde
associatif auquel nous accordons
beaucoup d'importance que nous aidons
dès que nous le pouvons vous deviez des
enveloppes que nous accorde le
département et je pense que ça a permis
de faire avancer un certain nombre de
dossiers notamment liée à la diminution
des dotations auquel les communes sont
soumises
et donc ce sont
une dizaine que nous pouvons apporter
mais à côté de ça nous intervenons de
façon conséquente notamment pour
représenter le département sur des
sujets particulièrement variés tout ce
qui est en rapport avec sociales rsa
pour josiane hélène ce qui est en
rapport avec la mémoire est également
les collèges qu'on couvre ensemble mais
on n'évoquera plus un petit peu plus
dans le détail le collectif constate et
j'ai le plaisir dans mes fonctions de
vice présidente en charge de la
solidarité d'accompagner toute la
problématique du rsa en particulier et
cette problématique qui a fait beaucoup
parler d'elle depuis deux années mais
qui nous a permis de faire avancer le
dossier sur plusieurs volets alors juste
pour mémoire si vous ne le savez
peut-être pas le rsa est basé sur trois
piliers notre politique du rsa est basé
sur trois piliers le pilier ii du juste
droit il faut qu'une personne puisse
accéder rapidement à une haine quand
elle en a besoin
la politique bien évidemment du retour à
l'emploi
le à de rsa pour l'activité c'est la
priorité absolue est bien entendu aussi
cette grande mission de rsa bénévolat
qui est une situation de transition pour
faciliter le retour à l'emploi et
retrouver de la dignité
quand on a pendant longtemps été hors du
schéma habituel de travail et donc ça
nous a permis de faire beaucoup avancer
cette notion de solidarité pour la
retirer de l'assistanat parce que la
solidarité c'est apporter une aide
et ce n'est pas faire de l'assistanat
mais également pour générer des
économies dans des contextes
actuellement très très difficile de
diminution des dotations et d'une
assemblée qui doit porter toutes les
problématiques de son territoire ce qui
me concerne nos niveaux du conseil
départemental la prise en main mais
récupère pas souhaité me confier
la délégation de mémoire ce qui était
particulièrement important en cette
année de centenaire puisque comme vous
le savez tous nous avons commémorer le
centenaire de 14 18 avec bien évidemment
des implications importantes sur des
sites tels que celui du iphone si la
coop
ceci a eu également une incidence à
titre plus personnel puisque je suis
particulièrement engagée dans la
reconnaissance de la corporation force
et de ce qu ont suivi nos confrères
aient vent terre mais on ne peut pas
évoquer par les politiques en évoquant
seulement le passé il nous faut bien
évidemment et c'est en collaboration en
partenariat avec josiane mehlen parler
d'avenir notamment lorsque l'on songe à
une des principales délégations qui
conseil départemental à savoir sa
compétence pour les collèges de notre
canton et des collèges du canton de
façon générale sur le département et un
brin un livre blanc des collèges a été
mis en place un site pour arriver à
rattraper le retard qu'ils avaient été
pris pendant de trop nombreuses
décennies et ce qui nous concerne donc
directement par l'école pour les
collèges de lutterbach dans la
rénovation est quasiment terminé celui
de kingersheim
avec la rénovation qui est vraiment très
avancés avec notamment des fonds
particulièrement importantes qui ont été
versées pour la réhabilitation du
chauffage est bien sûr celui de
prestataire qui a une vraie un vrai
besoin de remise en état et se sont
souvent sion le togo deux cantons déjà
plus d'un aigle 5 millions d'euros qui
ont été investis dans nos collèges et ce
d'ici à la fin du plan qui est prévu
pour 2023
la statue sera par exemple plus de 4
millions d'euros d'investissement qui
sera réalisé par le département
je pense que ce qui est intéressant pour
nous c'est vraiment de pouvoir oeuvrer
dans la proximité de notre territoire
tout à l'heure nous l'avons évoqué en
lien avec nos associations avec les élus
les maires de notre canton pour apporter
une réponse aux problématiques locales
conjointement aux grandes problématiques
que ce qu'ils sont portés par le conseil
départemental d'une manière générale et
en parallèle nous avons un vrai défi qui
nous attend à savoir la fusion à venir
de l'alsace bien évidemment certains y
en avoir plus je crois que c'est un
premier pas qu'attendent véritablement
les alsaciens à la population aux élus à
tout le monde de se rassembler
pour que ce pas puissent éventuellement
aller vers quelque chose d'encore plus
importants par la suite